في حياتها كما في مماتها ارتبط اسم شيرين
ابو عقله بالقدس المحتله فعلى ارضها ولدت
وترعرعته عنها دفعت وفي ترابها ووري
جثمانها
ارتباط وثيق بالاصل والارض وبالقضيه
25 عاما نقلت خلالها شيرين بامانات معاناه
ابن مقدساته جراء انتهاكات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تطوق شرطه الاحتلال جميع
الابواب المؤديه الى المسجد الاقصى
فمن يدخل
في هذا الحي المقدسي الهادئ بالم يستعيد
من عرفها عن قرب ذكريات انسانه وفيه حظيت
وما تزال بحب واحترام وتقدير من الجميع
حافظت على هذه العلاقات تحدث ما تستشهد
انا لا اذكر انه هي علاقاتها انقطعت مع اي
حدا من من العلاقات منذ الطفوله وحتى يعني
كان عندها ارتباط في هذه المنطقه وانتماء
لهون حتى انها تحاول تتحوج من هاي المنطقه
متوفر خدماتها من هون عشان كمان
تدعم القدس وتكون دائما حاضره فيها
نحن في الطريق الى جنين كانت اخر رساله من
شيرين لحظات قبل استشهادها
على طول ذلك الطريق تقابلك شواهد تخلد
لذكرها فمن المدينه ومخيمها حيث غيبها
الموت نقلت شيرين ابو عاقله الى العالم
معاناه اهالي جنين مع الاحتلال عبر قصص
كثيره فاضحت بعد اغتيالها هي ايضا قصه
توثق لسجله الاجرامي الحافل الاخت شيرين
يعني كل العالم يعلموا كل الشعب الصيني
قدمت لجنيه الكثير وكل اهل جنين معظم اهل
جنين المؤنبه يعني تعذروه اخت ومناظره
ورمز وايقونه ضحت في حياته سبيل الجنين
مخيم جنوب العارثي وقباطي وبركين ذكرى
شيرين الانسانه والصحافيه حيه في وجدان كل
من عرفها من بعيد او قريب
ومنذ ان اختلط قوات الاحتلال شهيده
الحقيقه والكلمه هنا قبل عام يخلد ابناء
شعب احب شيرين اسمها كل يوم في كل ركن من
وطنها فلسطين
منذ استشهادها اطلقت مبادرات فلسطينيه
عديده تخليدا لذكرى شيرين ابو عقله
اوسمه وجوائز ومنح دراسيه واطلاق اسمها
على مرافق ومؤسسات
الجامعه العربيه الامريكيه قدمت منحه
دراسيه باسم الشهيده في الاعلام الرقمي
لدراسه البكالوريوس
وهنا في مستشفى جنين توضع اللمسات الاخيره
قبيل اطلاق اسم الشهيده على مركز الطوارئ
سيتم تسميه قسم الطوارئ في مستشفى جنين
باسم الشهيده المرحومه شيرين ابو عاقله
فهي رمز للشجاعه والانسانيه
والوحده والحقيقه للشعب الفلسطيني حيث
انها استشهدت بالقرب من المستشفى وتم
نقلها الى قسم الطوارئ كانت شيرين ابو
عاقله دوما قريبه من هموم ومعاناه الانسان
الفلسطيني تحولت بعد استشهادها الى ايقونه
خالده وملهمه تبعث الامل في شعب صامد بوجه
الاحتلال وانتهاكاته
امين الجزيره الضفه الغربيه